[Musique]
oui
que les autres
et bien entendu parler des drive mais
pour moi c'était une vision assez
vieille du drag les enfin c'était pas du
tout la vision actuelle
j'ai pas envie de devenir une femme tu
vois c'est vraiment un personnage que je
joue et le fait de voir que les gens
acceptent accepte les dragues en soirée
et qu'ils disent au final c'est fun
aussi beau qu'à pas de jugement c'est
beau ce qu'elle fait ça m'a beaucoup
aidé après afin à vouloir me lancer dans
drive
ma première aventure c'est georges hamel
a fait ressortir moche j'ai pas réussi
[Musique]
c
je le parle d'art
avant il n'y avait pas beaucoup de drag
queen on sait que les ai tous maintenant
quand je vais dans une soirée drap genre
je connais presque personne moi je vois
une petite meuf comme ça je fait équipe
oui maintenant on a créé de chaud pour
nous il ya beaucoup de soirées drague
c'est toutes les semaines on est
beaucoup plus métier de médiatiser
maintenant on y est devenu beaucoup plus
inscrits au nous la génération europol
on est plutôt une génération où on
utilise notre corps comme un outil
artistique c'est une expression artistes
de drague c'est une expression
artistique
on s'en fout du genre parce que je
trouve qu'il ya quand même du total
devant fait qu'il considère qu' il faut
rassembler une femme à l'emprunt ce
n'est pas du tout le cas maintenant son
ensemble 10 alien c'est parce que c'est
une autre interprétation du drag c'est
pas du tout à une moquerie de la femme
c'est plutôt créer une créature avec
quelques traits féminins oups est
masculin
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
alors je mieux parce que je m'intéresse
beaucoup à la culture gay en général et
aux cieux drag queen et j'ai entendu
parler de cet endroit sur instagram et
je suivais les queen dont le coût qui je
me suis dit que j'allais venir et
c'était vachement coach et avec tous les
évènements du mariage pour tous par
exemple avant tout la manif pour tous
qui a eu et tous ces espèces de relents
homophobie qui commencent à apparaître
ben jama encore plus envie et besoin de
s'exprimer de dire qu'on était là
est-ce qu'on est arrivé ou est ce qu'on
arrive petit à petit a créé des endroits
sûrs et safe où chacun peut s'exprimer
ouvertement go chacun peut laisser
sortir sa féminité ou sa masculinité de
manière hyper
safe est ce que on a une génération de
comédiens plus important puisqu'il faut
pas oublier que les drapés ils sont
avant tout des comédiens tout est très
esthétique
il faut les voir se préparer c'est entre
4 et 6 heures de préparation c'est une
vraie performance asti artistique et de
comédie en fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non